welcome back to Python tutorials with
simply learn I'm Angela and today we
look into dictionaries and sets in
Python so first let's have a look at
what a dictionary is by definition a
dictionary is an unordered collection of
data stored as a pair of key and value
so dictionary basically is another data
type just like your lists and your
tuples but here they are not exactly a
sequence because the order in which you
store the elements are not very
important in the case of a dictionary
also every element is a pair of values
so there's the key and there's the value
the key is basically like your index in
a list or a tuple but here in
dictionaries keys can be not just
integers but also strings so that is the
main difference between dictionaries and
are the sequences such as lists and
tuples now let's have a look at exactly
how this works but first we look at its
syntax so you have your variable name or
the dictionary name equal to and within
curly braces you have your data stored
so each data here is a key value pair as
I mentioned earlier so our first data
would be key 1 and then you have the
double colons so the double colon
basically separates the key and the
value so value 1 is assigned to key 1
value 2 is assigned to key 2 and so on
and every pair of value and key is
separated by a comma so now we will move
to Jupiter notebook to have a look at
how dictionaries work let's start with
creating dictionaries so first we'll
make an empty dictionary so how is this
done you have your variable name which
will be a dictionary name basically so
I'm taking my variable name as d1 and as
we previously saw dictionary elements
are enclosed within curly braces so you
can just put down curly braces here and
since you are creating an empty
dictionary have no element inside and
that is pretty much it that's how you
create an empty dictionary I'll just
print this out print d1 also print out
its type so as you see here guys this is
an empty dictionary the class is ticked
the short for dictionary of course now
let's create a dictionary with elements
so my dictionary name this time would be
d2 again curly braces and now within
these
races will enter our elements so my
first elements key is save one and the
value assigned to this key would be
welcome my second elements key is to
value assigned to this would be to third
key and third value and finally the
fourth key and it's corresponding fourth
value now let me print d2 out so we
created our second dictionary
successfully now here these integers are
the keys and these strings are the
values now I mentioned previously to
that in case of dictionaries the keys
are like indices but here these indices
slash keys do not need to be integers
they can also be strings so next up
let's create a dictionary with the keys
being strings too so my next
dictionaries name is d3 and now within
curly braces enter your elements again
so my first element key would be name
the double colon and then enter the name
although name is a key since it's still
a string we need to enter them in double
quotes do not forget that the next key
would be age which is 22 and finally the
profession and Sam here is a student so
that's a dictionary d3 I'll print this
out too so we created an empty
dictionary we created a dictionary with
its indices as just integers and others
another method of creating dictionaries
which is using the dict method so let's
check this out
my dictionary name is defo and i'll be
using the dictionary method now I'll
pass the dictionary elements within the
dictionary method again using curly
braces now this kind of creation of a
dictionary is not needed the above
methods are so much more simpler and
that's what we usually go with but just
for the sake of your knowledge we'll
check this out too so again I'll just
put down these elements here copy-paste
them inside these curly braces and then
print out d4 so as you see it's just the
same thing we get the exact same result
using this dictionary method too
now when you're using the dictionary
method make sure that you have not named
any variable as dict previously in that
case if you did name any variable when
you put down this method it will give
you an error saying
thought is not callable so if you did by
mistake create a variable or a method
saying dit make sure you delete it
before you run this line now another
syntax for using that method and
creating a dictionary let's look at that
so now my dictionary is d5 using that
method again so this time will pass
every key and its corresponding value as
a pair within round rackets so we are
basically passing these pairs as
elements of a list or by syntax you can
say as tuples within a list so you have
one is welcome remember to put the
quotes always for Strings too so as you
notice in this case we are not using the
double colons what we are doing is to
the method we are passing a list of
pairs of the elements and each of these
pairs are enclosed within these round
brackets here now print out D 5 so
there's an error here the error is of
course that we have double colons in
space of comma so I'll correct that and
run the code again and there you go
so D 5 is also created it's exactly the
same as D 2 or D 4 it's just a different
method of creating it now the final type
of dictionary that will be creating our
nested dictionaries so you can have a
dictionary within a dictionary just like
you can have a list within a list or a
tuple within ductal so let's see how
this is done and why this would be done
too so if you look at d3 here we had
this key name which had 1 values Sam but
now what if our key name has two values
that's the first name and the second
name now in this case name can be the
key to another dictionary and within
this dictionary we can store the first
and the second name again with a
corresponding keys so we look at that I
have my dictionary d6 here and we'll use
a simple method of creating a dictionary
I'll just copy paste this line where I'm
storing Sam's details and edit this out
so name is the key to a dictionary and
within this dictionary I'll have two
keys first which is basically your first
name that is Sam and last that Sam's
last name which is Cru and that's how
you create a nest
dictionary print d6 out so it's done as
you can see here meme is the key for our
dictionary which is inside and main
dictionary and inside this nested
dictionary too
we have two keys first and last each of
them with values so now that we learned
how to create dictionaries let's see how
you can add more elements to them so
I'll create an empty dictionary first
say D and now I want to add my first
element to this dictionary so I can see
D of 0 just like how you do in case of
lists
equal to and the value then I'll print
out D so that's how it's done
0 becomes your key and welcome is the
value now I can also add a topple to
this dictionary so if I have on my
second element or the value of key 1 to
be a topple I go like D of 1 equal to
and then just how you would define a
double go ahead and create that
and then I'll print out D so now we have
two elements in our dictionary D the
first is the string welcome followed by
a topple with 3 elements so I just
missed out a comma here and forgot to
close my strings so yeah our dictionary
has two elements the first one is a
string welcome and the second element is
a couple with 3 elements within it which
are how are entering you so so far we
use numbers as indices for adding
elements which may the number the key
now as you saw previously dictionaries
can also have keys which are strings so
how do you assign these well the same
way but now instead of number put down a
string and I CD of name equal to Sam
right and then print out D so our first
two elements have the key 0 and 1
integers our last element is having the
key as name which is a string and a
value which is again a string now
similarly you can also add dictionary as
an element to this already existing
dictionary now in this particular case
our own add another element in fact I
want to update the value of a key name I
want the value to be another dictionary
just like we had previously
so I'll again say name where the index
is supposed to be and then equal to
curly braces where I'll create my
dictionary so that will be
the key first which will have the values
Sam and the key lust which will have the
value crew shrink D out and there you go
so your value for the key name has been
updated now so we saw how we can add
elements or update elements now let's
have a look at how you can access the
elements which are already present in
your dictionary so the syntax we use
again here is very similar to that for
lists or tuples before we move ahead
though I'll just print out D so that we
can refresh us to whatever was storing
deep so we have three elements here key
zero has a value welcome key one with
the tupple how are you and then finally
key three which is named which has a
dictionary assets value and the
dictionary holds the first and the last
name so now if I want to retrieve the
value of the key name I can just say D
of name and I will give you the value of
the key name now if I want the value of
just the key first which is within the
key name I can go ahead with the sort of
syntax you'd use for lists and tuples
again when they are nested so D of name
which returns this dictionary here as we
saw previously and now from this
dictionary if I want to extract the
value of the key first then I would just
say first within these square brackets
and that is how you retrieve the value
within a nested dictionary now this is a
very simple method yet again we have a
method which is specific for saving
values with dictionaries which is the
get method so if I say D dot get off and
within the brackets I passed the key say
one runs line here and that two
retrieves the value of the particular
key so we created dictionaries we
inserted elements into it updated those
elements and even saw how to access
these elements now let's look at how you
can delete the elements so once again
before we begin I'll just print out our
dictionary on which we'll be operating
so that's D and these are the elements
within D now the first method that you
can use for deleting elements is the pop
method so I'll say d dot pop off and
the bracket in Siddiqui whose values you
wanna delete so suppose I want to delete
welcome which is at key zero so I just
enter zero in here run the code and the
pop method basically deletes the value
for the key that's given and it returns
this value so it's returned welcome also
if we check D now welcome won't exist
within two anymore now the other method
which is popularly used for deleting
elements is pop item now with pop we
specified the element we want to delete
with pop item we do not specify this
element because it's always the last
element of the dictionary so you just
say d dot pop item run the code again
pop item just like pop returns the
element while deleting it also so I'll
print out D now and as you see here D
just has one element left after the two
deletions which is the value of key one
and that's basically how you delete
elements from a dictionary now we'll
also check out some inbuilt methods or
inbuilt functions with dictionaries
before we move on to that though we put
a dictionary back into its previous
state so we'll just run the line where
we created our dictionary once more this
line here let's check out D now so our
dictionaries back to its original state
and now we can perform the next few
operations on them so there are a number
of inbuilt functions used with
dictionaries but here we'll just focus
on some of the very important and
commonly used ones so the first one
you're going to look at is values so you
say d dot values off now what this
function does it returns all the values
of the dictionary so it returns Jesse
values not the case run this so as you
can see here all the values are returned
as a dict values type object now there's
a slightly different method of creating
a dictionary which is using the from
keys function so what this function does
is basically it takes two sequences one
for the keys and one for the value and
then it creates a dictionary using these
keys and values so first I'll create a
sequence for my keys my keys would be
ABCD and then I just have one single
value here one and I want each of these
keys to have the value as one so
this is where the frumpkis method comes
very handy save dick dot from keys and
then you pass on the sequence of keys
and the value let's run the command so a
dictionary is created here with our keys
ABCD and as I mentioned previously you
can probably notice here the best that
dictionaries are unordered so just
because I gave the sequence as ABCD does
not mean that the sequence or this order
will hold in the dictionary that's
created and now finally we'll use the
clear method to completely remove this
dictionary now if I try to print D here
it's an empty dictionary so with that we
come to an end of what dictionaries is
and next we look at sets so what are
sets in Python by definition a set is an
unordered collection of unique elements
so the terms we must concentrate on here
are unordered just like dictionaries in
set also there's no particular order to
the element stored in it also unique
elements as in suppose you have the
letter a and you enter this twice while
creating the set ultimately when the set
is stored or when you print out the set
you'll notice that a only occurs once so
every element of the set is unique now
set basically brings out the
mathematical notion of a set that means
you can easily find out the union of two
sets or the intersection of two sets or
any such operation that you'd normally
do on mathematical sets also sets are
iterable and mutable and they provide a
very optimized way of checking if an
element is within it or not now let's
have a look at the syntax of a set you
have the variable name or the set name
equal to and then you use the set method
to create the set you pass to this a
list of the elements that you want
inside the set so unlike dictionaries in
sets you don't have key value pairs it's
just the values now we will move back to
our Jupiter notebook to demonstrate sets
so first things first let's create a set
my set name would be s and then I'll use
the set method and within this I'll pass
4 elements 1 2 3 4 and that's how I
create my set very simple isn't it I
will just print out my set
and also print out its type so we can
confirm that what stored in s is
actually a set run the code so as you
see here we have our set one two three
four belongs to the class set now sets
need not have just integers or just
strings it can be mixed of course and we
look at this while also looking at how
we can add elements to a set so for
adding elements he used the add method
so s dot add off and then within the
brackets you pass whatever the element
is that you want to add in this
particular case I'm adding a so I'll run
that and then print out s so yes a is
added to the end of the set but again
since this is a set the order does not
matter so now sets are mutable so I was
able to add a new element to the set now
we have another thing called frozen set
now frozen sets are just like sets
except they are immutable
so here I'll create a frozen set for
which we use the function again called
frozen set pass on the elements here and
then I will print out FS so the syntax
for creating a frozen set is just like
that for creating a set and yeah we have
the elements here now I want to add an
element to FS if I say FS add off and
pass a here you'll notice you get an
error and the error sees that attribute
add is not associated with frozen set
this simply because add modifies the set
and frozen cells do not allow this kind
of a modification now as I mentioned
before set in Python repressing the
notion of sets in Max so that means that
we can also have operations at as Union
and intersection on set and these are
the most common operations that you do
perform with sets so let's have a look
at these so I'll create two set
initially s1 which will have the
elements 1 3 7 2 and then s2 having the
elements 3 2 8 9 so these are our two
sets now first we apply the Union
operation so you say s1 dot Union off
and within the brackets pass s to run
this so what Union does
is it brings all the elements of s1 and
s2 together into another set and of
course any kind of reputation is removed
cassettes have unique elements so as you
can see here you have three in s1 and s2
both but three appears just once in our
union set now we can also have
intersection of s1 and s2 now we can
also subtract a set from another so s1
dot difference of s2 basically removes
all the elements from s1 which are also
found in s2 run this line here and the
result is 1 & 7 so we'll go back to our
list here and confirm this now s1 has 1
3 7 2 but s2 has elements 3 & 2 so when
you remove s2 from s1 all you're left
with is 1 & 7 now there are certain
operators that you can use with set and
this is really interesting to view
because these kind of operators
generally only worked with numbers or
boolean expressions as such so let's
check these out
now we can easily check if two sets are
equal s1 equal to equal to s2 just like
you check with numbers run this of
course s1 and s2 are not equal
now similarly you can also check if a
set is greater than the other s 1
greater than s2 so what this does is it
checks every element basically so here
it'll check if 1 is greater than 3 no
it's not so at the very first iteration
itself
s1 is not greater than s2 that's
definitely a false now remember how I
initially said that it's very optimized
to check with set if an element exists
within it or not so this is where the in
operator comes into picture now if I
want to check if one is an element in s1
all I have to do is go like one in s1 so
if one is an element in s1 which is true
in our case it will return true and if I
say like 61 in s1 that will return false
because 61 is not in s1 there's also a
negative to this which is not in so if I
say 1 not in s1 that will return false
because 1 is definitely in s1 and
similarly we also have the exclusive
operator s1 exclusive or s2 so what this
operator does is basically it returns
all the elements which are exclusively
either in s1 or s2 so if we go back to
our set here we'll see one is an s-1 and
not an s2 3 is in both of them 7 is
again exclusive to s1 and similarly 8
and 9 are exclusive to s2 so I'll run
this line here and that's exactly what
we got 1 7 8 9 so there are a number of
operations which are performed with sets
the thing is set in general are not very
widely used so here we have discovered
some of the common features which I use
with sets if at all sets are used and
with that we come to an end of a python
tutorial on dictionaries and set if you
have any questions please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you
also hit the like button if you like
this video and please subscribe to our
channel if you have not yet because we
have a lot more great videos coming up
so stay tuned and I'll see you all next
time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here